Número dos: divorcio.
Tres: separación conyugal.
En general, pero no siempre,
para que esos tres ocurran,
necesitamos lo que viene en el número siete de la lista,
que es el matrimonio.
(Risas)
Cuarto en la lista está el encarcelamiento en una institución.
Algunos dicen que el número siete se ha contado dos veces.
(Risas)
No creo eso.
Cuando se construyó el inventario de estrés vital,
una relación a largo plazo se equiparaba a un matrimonio.
No es así ahora para los propósitos de esta charla,
voy a estar incluyendo
que las relaciones vienen antes de los matrimonios y matrimonios homosexuales
o de relaciones del mismo género, pronto espero que se conviertan en matrimonios.
De mi trabajo con parejas del mismo género,
lo principal de lo que estoy por hablar
no es diferente, son iguales en todas las relaciones.
Así que en una sociedad moderna, sabemos que la prevención
es mejor que la cura.
Vacunamos contra la polio, la difteria, el tétanos, la tos ferina, el sarampión.
Tenemos campañas de sensibilización para el melanoma,
el accidente cerebrovascular, la diabetes.
Todas campañas importantes
pero ninguna de esas enfermedades
llegan a afectar al 45 %.
Al 45 %. Ese es nuestra tasa actual de divorcio.
¿Por qué no hay campaña de prevención para el divorcio?
Creo que se debe a que nuestros políticos no creen que cosas como la atracción
y la forma en que se construyen las relaciones
pueda cambiarse o enseñarse.
¿Por qué?
Bueno, nuestros políticos son de la Generación X.
Tienen entre treinta y tantos y cincuenta y tantos.
Cuando hablamos de estos temas veo sus ojos vidriados,
y puedo ver que piensan: ¿No lo entiende este psiquiatra loco?
No se puede controlar la forma en que las personas atraen a otras personas
y construyen relaciones.
No es así, nuestros queridos millennials.
Esta es la generación más conectada, analítica y escéptica
que toma las decisiones más informadas de cualquier generación anterior.
Y cuando hablo con los millennials, tengo una reacción muy diferente.
Quieren saber de esto.
Quieren saber cómo tenemos relaciones que duran.
Así que para quienes quieren abrazar la era post-romántica del destino conmigo,
permítanme hablar de mis tres consejos de vida para evitar el divorcio.
Ahora podemos intervenir para evitar el divorcio en dos puntos posteriores.
Una vez que las grietas empiecen a aparecer en una relación establecida
o antes de que nos comprometamos,
antes de que tengamos hijos y de eso hablaré ahora.
Así que mi primer consejo de vida:
Los “millennials” pasan siete horas más en sus dispositivos al día.
Datos estadounidenses, y algunos dicen, quizá con razón,
que esto tal vez ha afectado
sus relaciones cara a cara.
Sumemos a eso la cultura de la conexión, aplicaciones como Tinder,
y no es una gran sorpresa que los veinteañeros con los que trabajo
a menudo me hablen de cómo
es más fácil tener relaciones sexuales con alguien que han conocido.
Tenemos una conversación significativa.
Algunos dicen que esto es algo malo.
Yo digo que es algo muy bueno.
Es particularmente bueno tener relaciones sexuales
fuera de la institución del matrimonio.
Pero antes de plantearme reparos morales, recuerden que la Generación X,
en el Informe Público Estadounidense
hallaron que el 91 % de las mujeres
habían tenido relaciones sexuales prematrimoniales
a los 30 años, el 91 %.
Es particularmente bueno que estas relaciones estén sucediendo más tarde.
Verán, los boomers en los años 60
se casaban,
en promedio las mujeres a los 20 y los hombres a los 23.
En 2015 en Australia ahora es 30 para las mujeres y 32 para los hombres.
Eso es bueno, porque cuanto mayor seas cuando te casas,
menor será tu tasa de divorcio. ¿Por qué?
¿Por qué es útil casarse más tarde?
Por tres razones.
En primer lugar, casarse más tarde permite que entren en juego
factores que evitan el divorcio.
Se trata de la educación terciaria y de un ingreso más elevado,
que tiende a ir con la educación terciaria.
Estos tres factores se confunden.
Dos: La investigación en neuroplasticidad nos dice que el cerebro humano
sigue creciendo hasta al menos los 25 años.
Eso significa que la manera de pensar y lo que uno piensa
sigue cambiando hasta los 25.
Y en tercer lugar, y lo más importante para mí, es la personalidad.
La personalidad a los 20 años
no se correlaciona con la personalidad a los 50 años.
Y la personalidd a los 30 se correlaciona con la personalidad a los 50 años.
Cuando le pregunté a alguien que se casó joven, por qué rompieron dijeron:
“Nos separamos”.
Fueron sorprendentemente precisos porque los veintitantos
es una edad de rápido cambio y maduración.
Lo primero que quieres antes de casarte es ser mayor.
(Risas)
Número dos:
John Gottman, psicólogo e investigador de relaciones
puede hablarnos de muchos factores que se correlacionan
con un matrimonio feliz y exitoso, pero quiero hablar de algo importante.
El 81 % de los matrimonios implosionan, se autodestruyen
si este problema está presente.
Quiero hablar de ello aquí porque es algo que pueden evaluar
en sus citas.
Gottman encontró que las relaciones más estables y felices
a largo plazo eran relaciones en las que la pareja compartía el poder.
Eran influenciables.
Grandes decisiones como comprar una casa,
viajar al exterior, comprar un coche, tener hijos.
Pero cuando Gottman profundizó en estos datos,
encontró que las mujeres eran generalmente bastante influenciables.
¿Adivinan dónde estaba el problema?
Sí, hay dos opciones aquí.
Sí, los hombres teníamos la culpa.
La otra cosa que encontró Gottman es que los hombres influenciables
también solían ser “¡padres sobresalientes!”
Así que mujeres, ¿qué tan influenciable es su hombre?
Hombre:
Estás con ella porque la respetas.
Asegúrate de que hay respeto en la toma de decisiones.
Número tres.
A menudo me intriga por qué las parejas vienen a verme
después de haber estado casados durante 30 o 40 años.
Es el momento en el que se acercan a las enfermedades de la vejez,
en el que están particularmente enfocados en cuidarse unos a otros.
Perdonarán cosas que les han molestado durante años.
Perdonarán las viejas traiciones, incluso las infidelidades,
porque están enfocados en cuidar.
Entonces, ¿qué los separa?
La mejor palabra que tengo para esto es la fiabilidad o la falta de fidelidad.
¿Tu pareja te da la espalda?
Adopta dos formas.
En primer lugar, ¿puedes confiar en que tu pareja haga lo que dice que va a hacer?
¿Es consecuente?
En segundo lugar: si, por ejemplo, estás fuera,
te atacan verbalmente
o sufres una enfermedad realmente incapacitante,
¿tu pareja está presente y hace lo que hay que hacer
para que sientas cuidado y protección?
Este es el problema.
Si te enfrentas a la vejez y tu pareja no hace eso por ti,
de hecho, tienes que hacerlo por tu pareja,
y eso en una relación ya frágil
puede parecer como si uno estuviera mejor fuera que dentro de la relación.
¿Tu pareja está ahí para ti cuando realmente importa?
No todo el tiempo, el 80 % del tiempo, pero sobre todo si es importante.
Por tu lado, piensa cuidadosamente
antes de comprometerte a hacer algo por tu pareja.
Es mucho mejor comprometerse
dentro de lo posible,
que comprometerse con lo que suena bien en el momento y luego decepcionar.
Y si es realmente importante para tu pareja y te comprometes con ello,
asegúrate de que mueves cielo y tierra para seguir adelante.
Esto que digo es algo que pueden buscar.
Cosas que se pueden construir y relaciones existentes.
Creo que la decisión más importante que pueden tomar
es a quién eligen como pareja en la vida,
a quién eligen como par para tener a sus hijos.
Y, por supuesto, tiene que haber romance,
el romance es algo grandioso hermoso y peculiar.
Pero tenemos que añadir a un corazón romántico y amoroso,
una mente reflexiva informada
conforme tomamos la decisión más importante de nuestra vida.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)